I plug in my iPhone whenever I have a
phone right Samsung
okay
gotta be Samsung all right Samsung I
plug in my Samsung
um doesn't matter what kind of TV I'm
looking at or the Toshiba
yeah yeah
um a tube TV no less like an old tube so
I assume just by your thinking okay I'm
wearing a kimono 100 what else would you
be wearing at your house
and
what's in it what's holding your hair up
a jump Chopsticks that's correct my
grandma just passed away we had to go to
the wake is open yeah it's Irish wakes
you the way at an Irish wake the day
before the funeral did you kiss her it
didn't even look like her anymore I was
like oh
the soul of her or who she really was is
gone it's just the shell is left so it
was kind of this weird
like relief for me a little bit I was
like oh yeah the thing I loved the human
that the or the entity that she was that
I loved it's not even in there anymore
anyway it's gone to somewhere better and
you know in the universe down
hell baby yeah hell baby she was evil
dude
you don't know dude anyway how are you
thanks for being a bad friend are we
done yeah we're done
are you really I was just joking man I
was being dead serious I'm sorry you
made fun of me all the time when I'm
serious I said I'm not kidding three
times
so you understand that
um I didn't have sex with a woman until
I was 23.
until I started doing stand-ups yeah sex
with a guy before that I sucked a couple
of days
it's an animal in Chicago
the grizzly animal
in Chicago your mom
it's funny
that Grizzly animal
don't talk about my mother well it's
just a joke
relax yeah my mother's very pretty she's
a beautiful woman unlike your cross-eyed
mother don't you you don't have to
[__] get I'm not Bobby mother I'm I'm
Bobby mom
you're so [__] mean dude that's your
skin color anyway um your mom you know
what your mom looks like what your mom
looks like you know when kids dress up
as old people yeah and they're where
that's what your mom looks like a kid
that's wearing a mask black people
really like me a lot I get more black
people on my show than you do for sure
that's not even let's make a bet the
next show I go to I'm gonna let's see if
in Atlanta I'll get black people in
Spokane Washington okay no you won't not
like me yeah and I'll get the good ones
hello
leave it in
every rate you know what no I'll stand
by what could that even mean I know what
did I even mean you know what and I'll
get everyone to come to my show on time
what could that even mean
let me if I were to guess
um
you've had sex with one person okay
first of all first of all first of all
that's illegal to ask Saturday
can I take it back no it's over he's
gonna sue us we're [__] let me take
it Blow Your up let me give me because
I'm gonna go different direction please
I really said do you believe in God is
that better what are you doing
let me ask you something Max is that
your name right yeah yeah how old are
you I'm 20.
who are you living he lives here I live
here I know but where like down the
street but in an apartment no with my
parents
that's mean it's at this time of year I
have allergies oh is that what it was
right and so it just comes out get him
some Claritin yeah yeah I'm sorry get
him some credit then yeah with an R so
let me ask you something
a little different he's 20 years old I
didn't do anything why are you making
fun of him he's like 40 years younger
than you
[Laughter]
I'm on Sex in the City it's great yeah
that's great and my you know what I'm
playing
um some not definitely not someone she
has sex with
it's just a guess
why do you say that do you have sex with
someone on the show
who are you gonna vote for in the
November election yeah uh
d-o-n-a-l-d-t-r-o-u-mm
see
yeah I feel very comfortable this is why
we built the wall yeah we built the wall
for you we're gonna build the wall with
the bodies the dead Democrats a black
guy walks into a bar
and the bartender says get the [__] out
you get it say it again
I didn't get it I honestly didn't get it
say it again I think I missed it
so let me just like a black guy let me
just say it yeah is this what you said
a black guy
walks into a bar yeah and the bartender
says
get out get the [__] out get the [__]
out yeah
and then the black guy what happened he
leaves
and then what happens the bartender
where's the funny it's been it's the
bartender continues to serve the whites
and the bar oh
can I but some societies like Koreans
when they might have a God complex but
they don't have a history of Oppression
oppressing another group of people
each other right are you [__] out of
your mind what the [__] you don't think
Asians had they didn't Korean Koreans
didn't have slaves we didn't fly did
Koreans have slaves yeah Google that
yeah because I think that's wrong
somebody built them pyramids it wasn't
just somebody like you know we're gonna
go home
unbroken chain of slavery of any society
in history spanning 1500 years
[__] off that's not what it says stupid
in my eyes are blurry
I want to read it read it out loud piece
of [__] good close all right Korea
had the longest unbroken chain of
slavery of any society in history
was so difficult to get what do you mean
oh to like get as a girlfriend yeah I
mean it was I I was like I might have
people to get this one yeah first of all
what none of us thought so
when I first saw kalila I was like and I
met her not when I saw her how about
this take away just her that she's
pretty yeah when I saw that she was so
cool and nice and sweet yeah I I was a
little annoyed yeah yeah
so that was your girlfriend who is this
lady though you know what maybe I too
could be ninja
I want to be Ninja
[Music]
I want to jump jump down to Chinatown I
want to be ninja
I started
I am a natural that's
hard I fight with credit card I use my
numb chucks even while feeding dogs
will you stop it look at this look at
this Asian lady
first of all this is what this video
came out a long time ago but I saw it
again oh yeah let's just share the
chorus again no please don't turn it's
gonna put me to work
without
[Music]
I learned by ninja kicks while watching
Netflix I try to do everything like on
the big screen and you guys you know
what I might do it I might be a ninja
soon you know what this reminds me you
know who this is by the way who's that
this is a girl that sells murphy beds in
Orange County that's she did this as a
promo to sell Murphy Beds you know
Murphy Beds Are No the beds that go in
the wall the cabinet what the cabinet
beds you know they pop out of the
cabinets have you ever seen that I don't
know
old time Murphy bed yeah that's what
she's selling she's like a she opened a
Murphy bed company this is like years
ago yeah but this is she put this out
for promo let's see the course one more
time I don't want to hear this it's one
of my favorite courses
[Music]
she almost a ninja
down to Chinatown take ciao down to
Chinatown
this is the most racist [__] I've ever
heard in my life and it makes me laugh
so hard